all right crazy [ __ ] let's do it give
me something good
oh damn bad roll very very bad roll
because this slot turns the heart too
into an unfortunately large and
cumbersome youtube subscribe button that
will not revert until everybody watching
this video has pressed it so please for
the love of crazy slots free me from
this burden and at the same time sign
yourself up for some regular hunt under
content upload it straight until YouTube
feed doesn't seem like the worst deal in
the world right hello and welcome to the
new world review your source for
everything anime and manga and today
it's time to talk about both
specifically in regards to hunter hunter
and quite possibly the most
controversial change between the
original manga and the 2011 anime being
kites introduction into the series as
well as the quite radical overall effect
that it would go on to have to the anime
medium and if you're an anime only
watcher of hunter hunter or perhaps even
a manga in the radon show there are at
least a few of you that exist and you
may not necessarily know what I'm
talking about in which case I'm about to
somewhat blow your mind and for the sake
of source material I'm going to start
with these events as they occurred in
the manga so for anime only watches fun
fact here kite is actually technically
the very first character we ever see in
the series which is an honor bestowed to
him by placing him on the chapter 1 call
the spread alongside gone well there
since we read manga right to left kite
is technically our first character but
wait why does he appear so early on
given that he doesn't get involved
properly until the events of the chimera
and talk well he appears because kite is
actually everything the story then goes
on to open as per the anime with gone
catching the master of the swamp and
expressing his desire to take the hunter
exam as per his deal with Mito
shortly after this gone encounters the
Fox back on who is removed from this
portion in the 2011 anime and we enter a
flashback with when gone first met Kon
an event in which anime watchers will
remember sort of took place during
episode 76 a fair fairly into the series
and furthermore in the anime this
happens as a short montage rather than
actually playing out the scene which
we'll get into but not giving it room to
breathe is a big problem as you will see
but as the events play out in which kite
strikes down Khan's mother in order to
save gone and then he eventually
discovers that gone as the son of Jing
kite then tells gone all about Jing the
two of them bond and kite leaves with
jinx hunters license left mysteriously
on the floor were gone to pick up
effectively issuing our plucky own
protagonist a challenge to become a
hunter himself and find Jing afterwards
we cut back to them
one day God says goodbye to corn then
Mito and we're on a boat all in a single
beautiful chapter that lays out
everything right in front of us now as
for how the 2011 anime handled this the
kite flashback was removed entirely from
Episode one so gone basically captures
the master of the swamp says goodbye to
Mito and then it is boat time where the
entirety of the events of Chapter two
then go on to play out for the rest of
episode one now if you don't think that
this change is that all meaningful then
you are about to be very very surprised
but firstly if I had to offer an
explanation as to why this change was
made I'd say that it was to launch anime
viewers into the action with great haste
you guys remember at this point we
already had not only a manga story but
also in 1999 anime app tation and so the
2011 edition really needed to do
something to hook people early on which
as it would turn out would be to blast
through these initial chapters however
as much as I can see the short-term
benefit of this decision I now believe
that it was most certainly the wrong
choice to make because it would
negatively affect pretty much the entire
chimera arc which is craft of the bulk
of the series in retrospect as well as
give the overall story a bit more of a
flimsy commencement shall we say and
we'll discuss the latter first for the
sake of chronology which is that the
removal of the kite flashback is
effectively removing the call to
adventure for gone which is you know the
thing that the entire series is based on
meeting kite and receiving jinks hunters
license is the catalyst for this whole
adventure and in the 2011 anime there is
no groundwork laid in this regard we are
instead met with a young boy going on a
journey to become something we know
nothing about to find a character we
know nothing about in a world that we
know nothing about now the last part
isn't so important because you explore
the world as you go but missing all
three of these aspects is indeed a
problem and I think that this is best
epitomized in my wife's review of
episode 1 actually in which she spends a
great deal of time just being confused
by the situation presented to her she
had no idea what a hunter was or why god
wanted to be one and that is so so
important to allow us to get fully on
board with this character and the kite
flashback answers both of these
questions very satisfactorily because we
see what a hunter is in the form of kite
this kind of powerful and
environmentally aware being that is
something to look up to and aspire
towards and not only that but the fact
that this incredibly mature and
admirable being actively looks up to
Khan's father plants the seed into God's
imagination regarding exactly what kind
of phenomenal being Jing is and all of a
sudden you can very easily understand
why
gaun would actually want to find his
father in the first place because we as
an audience want to find Jing because
he's being conveyed as nothing less than
an incredible presence none of that is
present in the 2011 adaptation I
personally did not care whatsoever about
Jing when I watched it he was just
another guy in this world but I knew
nothing about as such Gunn's motivation
seems quite empty in comparison to the
manga events and yes you can make the
argument that the 2011 anime does cover
this eventually and adds context to it
but it's far far too late by then
because anyone who was not hooked as a
result of gongs vaguely presented
motivation has probably stopped watching
the series about 70 episodes prior to
this flashback actually being presented
so I get the way the anime did this gave
us some kind of boost in temporary
pacing but it reduced the overall hook
of hunter hunter because kite is meant
to be our shining example of what a
hunter is and provide the driving force
to delve into this journey to find Jing
but in the anime as far as I'm concerned
a boy caught a fish and then decided to
leave his Island for no adequately
explored reason and it's not just gone
that loses something very important to
motivation because this actually has a
much more profound effect on the
character of kite who as a result of the
manga events was a key figure and for
some comparison I would equate kite in
the manga to having the kind of role
that shanks would have in one piece
despite not appearing much throughout
series shanks was in chapter 1 and he
was that role model that was responsible
for igniting roofies dreams but now
imagine a one piece where we are never
given this context and luffy's Pirate
King ambition is devoid of all meaning
because who even cares about becoming
the Pirate King it has no emotional
resonance anymore however if we continue
with the comparison than like halfway
through the ground line Luffy suddenly
remembers shanks and why he wanted to
become the Pirate King in the first
place it would just completely devalue
shanks just as it does kind because in
the great wisdom of the otherwise fairly
brilliant 2011 series when gone
encounters kite for the first time he
doesn't even recognize the face of the
man who has had the most profound effect
on his entire life and when the
flashback does play out it happens in a
montage format which further devalues
the fact that this very moment was the
inception of hunter hunter as we know it
and to someone who first went through
the series with the 2011 anime I will
admit that the beginning of Hunter
hunter did not bother me so much
I had no idea what to expect and I just
accepted gone swims achill desires
however when we came to this point this
was a big problem for me the
fact that we had gotten 76 episodes in
and all of a sudden there was this
character of paramount importance being
wedged into the story and it just felt
incredibly wrong and it made ever so
much sense when I did decide to read the
manga afterwards but for this initial
impression kite felt like some sort of
poorly implemented brett con then when
you look at this event in the manga it
just plays out to perfection kite and
gone meet in the opening act of the
Chimera ant arc and they both recognize
each other immediately as if the bond
that they formed in Chapter one of the
series had never dulled it was a
fantastic reunion and you feel that as a
reader because here was a character who
effectively began the story and he had
now come back into it so there's a lot
of hype surrounding it as well because
you're like oh my god finally we get to
explore kite and that really does lead
to by far the biggest impact that this
decision had because you know God not
having his solid a motivation as he
could is one thing the clumsy retcon
flashback impacting a character is
another but the one thing that truly
serves as a detriment to the story is
the fact that removing this flashback
destroyed the relationship between gone
and kite which is the key to the Chimera
ant arc as well as God's crime acts in
the entirety of Hunter hunter
when I was watching the 2011 anime I had
some legitimate trouble understanding
why Gahan cared so much about kite
because there was just no reason to by
this point in the series gone has been
established as a kid who doesn't really
for major attachments to his mentor
figures I mean just imagine if wing or
Biscay had been killed yes it would have
had an emotional effect on him but I
don't see gone falling into the same
spiral of despair sorrow and anger that
would lead him to make such a suicidal
nan Val for the simple act of revenge
even if he did feel responsible for
their deaths and the entire reason why
Gaughan went down this path when kite
was involved because as it turns out
kite was far more than just a simple
mental figure if anything kite serves as
far more of an actual father figure then
[ __ ] would ever dream of being gone may
have only known kite for that one day
but during that day I took on an
incredibly important life lesson as well
as ignited Gaughan's passion for the
future and when they did finally reunite
during the Chimera ant arc kind
continued his fatherly nature all beard
in a brutal hunter a short of way but
with that context in mind God's
transformation makes so so much more
sense because in many ways he feels
responsible for killing the closest
person that he had ever had to a father
and that familial bond is going to do
some very power
things as we went on to see and the 2011
anime is missing this and while I
obviously couldn't identify exactly what
it was missing at the time I do vividly
recall not quite believing and
understanding why Gahan was seemingly
very suddenly pushed into this place of
pure darkness it just wasn't the sort of
thing that would come from meeting a
nice guy who was so unimportant to you
that you completely forgot about him as
a child and this is troublesome to me
because this is not just an arc specific
character journey this is gone
effectively done for the entire series
his feelings for kite culminated in him
taking himself out of action and
irrevocably changing Hunter hunter going
forward and not only that but Gahan was
only actually properly healed not by a
locker but by encountering and
apologizing to the reincarnated chimera
and kite which in the anime did very
little for me to be honest but at that
point I was beyond trying to understand
and empathize with why God cares so much
about a relationship that according to
what I'd seen had never really existed
so you would think that properly
building that relationship would be
absolutely the most important thing you
could possibly do with this anime series
but I guess not so if it came down to a
choice of adding one extra episode into
the hunter exam arc or maybe even half
an episode then I would easily take that
over undercutting the protagonists
emotional climax of the entire series
especially considering the hunter exam
arc is bogged down by a couple of
episodes of recap anyway and yeah I know
different considerations at play here
recaps are often put in place usually
for budgetary reasons but the fact that
they are there removes the argument of
pacing entirely so look I loved the 2011
enemy it was my first Hunter hunter
experience and I will praise it to the
end of my days for being a really super
solar product but even when I was
watching it without knowing what I do
now kite just felt off to me I didn't
like how suddenly important he was I
mean he was a cool character but we have
plenty of those so why did you need to
shoehorn your way into the main
protagonist childhood like you were some
kind of fanfic writers Oh see so I
really do wish that the anime had
preserved that relationship because that
dynamic as I keep saying is literally
everything that is hunter hunt up it is
the reason why the series begins and it
is the reason why Kahn's story ends
there is no other change in the anime
that I think actively hurts the series
there are other things they do question
but this is the only one that I find
completely unacceptable I still enjoyed
the 2011 anime but looking back on it it
just could have hit me so much harder if
it had just
stuck to the original telling of the
events so it's a really unfortunate flaw
from an otherwise fantastic anime
endeavor but what do you guys think
please do leave your thoughts in the
comments below
and if you're keen for some more hunt
onto content and please do check out my
other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for regular Clinton to Glory
delivered straight to your YouTube feed
but for now this has been the New World
review and I'll see you next time